The terrorist attacks
of September 11, 2001
continue to cast a long
shadow over American life.
20 years later,
at home and abroad,
the world is more chaotic and less free
because the U.S. government
exploited our fears
to erode our liberties
and launch two disastrous foreign wars.
This is an attack
on all that America is.
Every nation must take seriously,
the growing threat of terror
on a catastrophic scale.
Can we ever feel safe again?
Even just like the feeling of security,
I think is so important.
War has been declared...
Bill, you've got to
unleash the dogs of war.
Either you're with us,
or you are with the terrorists.
Today's defining crisis,
the COVID-19 pandemic, has created
another opportunity to restrict freedom
in the name of protecting
us from a fearsome enemy.
In this case,
a viral infection.
The breaking news, stay at home.
That is the order tonight.
These are people who are frightened
Stay home and stay away from others.
Certain amount of arm twisting
by governments is perfectly justified.
If everything is reopened,
then what's the carrot going to be?
I wasn't thinking of the bill
of rights when we did this
So what will the world look like
20 years from now?
9/11 led to illegal detentions, torture,
routine warrantless spying
on everyday Americans,
two wars, and an explosion
of government spending.
COVID-19 has brought
unconstitutional restrictions
on travel between states and cities,
vaccine and mask mandates,
lockdown orders that closed businesses,
schools, and churches,
restrictions on dining in restaurants
and exercising in gyms,
and an explosion of government spending.
Early in the pandemic,
President Trump invoked
the Defense Production Act
to compel businesses
to produce ventilators and other supplies
for combating the virus
when the federal government
didn't like the terms offered
after 9/11,
Congress created the
Department of Homeland Security
and nationalized airport
security by creating the TSA.
The federal government also
conscripted communications companies
into monitoring customers,
even going so far as to install
National Security Agency
equipment in AT&T facilities.
Politicians seem to understand
instinctively that a crisis
is an opening to push
freedom eroding policies
previously too hard to
get the public to accept.
Such as the disastrous war in Iraq,
which had nothing to do with the attacks.
But regime change in Iraq
had been on the wishlist of
senior Bush administration
officials long before 9/11
and the terrorist attack
created an opening.
You're going to get him out of there?
I'd like to, of course,
and I presume this
administration would as well.
For then Senator Biden,
the 9/11 attacks provided
an opening for railroading
through Congress
a bill that he had drafted
following the Oklahoma city bombing,
but that he couldn't get passed.
It became the Patriot act.
Almost the same thing that got passed,
The Patriot Act,
was introduced by me in 1994.
And it was the right
wing that defeated it.
20 years later,
even while correctly predicting
that the Supreme court
would overturn the order.
President Biden extended
an emergency federal eviction moratorium,
that was always based on faulty science,
violating the property rights
of millions of landlords.
September 11th reminds
us that dressed policies
and accumulated authority
have a nasty way of lingering
long after the emergencies
for which they were invoked
have come to an end.
It created an opportunity
for new government spending on initiatives
that had little to do with
keeping Americans safe.
Congress diverted billions
of dollars to often wasteful
"homeland security" spending,
including counter-terrorism
funding for small towns,
hundreds of miles from
major American cities.
Why would Al Qaeda to come Tiptonville?
If I were Al Qaeda,
and I wanted to get Memphis,
I'd come to Tiptonville.
No one would ever expect me here.
As 60 Minutes reported in 2005,
the money was spent on
transporting lawnmowers
to lawnmower races, Segways,
air conditioned garbage trucks,
bulletproof dog vests,
and decontamination units
nobody knew how to operate.
The people who view these as not necessary
I think are wrong.
Today's proverbial crisis
that's too good to waste
has led to trillions in
passed or proposed spending
for so-called recovery and infrastructure.
Somehow that's been defined
to include internet access,
child tax credits, electric
vehicle charging stations,
corporate subsidies, and
buy American mandates,
Everything, it turns out,
is a necessary expense
for fighting COVID-19 when
politicians see opportunity.
20 years from now,
we may well still be
living with crippling debt,
"emergency" government programs
that somehow were never phased out
and pandemic fueled
restrictions on our daily lives.
Or we'll look back at the
pandemic as a turning point
in which Americans
rediscovered their ability
to move past a crisis and reclaim control
over their own lives,
if we can break the
pattern set after 9/11,
the 20 year anniversary of
September 11, 2001 is a day
for mourning the loss of
the nearly 3000 people
who perished tragically
on that horrific day
and to dwell on how
political leaders used fear
to steal our liberties,
because history is already
repeating itself in ways
that we and our kids will live to regret.